sie wollen die Verfassung verteidigen
als rechtsextreme Bürgerwehr mit Gottes
Hilfe aber ohne jede Gewalt wirklich
gegen unsere Regierung in den Krieg
ziehen sondern nur überleben was immer
politisch passiert
vielleicht Leute wie die Clintons
enthaupten
sie lassen sich in den Bann schlagen von
ihrem Idol egal wie viele Gesetze er
gebrochen hat wie viele Lügen er
verbreitet
er ist noch unser Präsident was viele
nicht wissen
sie beten ihn an wie einen König
er warnt vor republikanischem
Extremismus dem Untergang der Demokratie
vor den Zwischenwahlen ist Amerika tief
gespalten als gäbe es zwei Amerikas ein
republikanisches und ein demokratisches
die Republikaner Streben mit
trumpistischen Kandidaten an die Macht
führen Wahlkampf ohne Tabus
ich hatte eine Großmutter mit Demenz
beiden ist auch so ein Fall
demokratie ist wenn die Mehrheit die
Minderheit zu todeknüppeln will das ist
Demokratie
Republikaner die Trumps wahllüge
widerlegen werden als Verräter
beschimpft und bedroht Anhänger beider
Parteien können sich kaum vorstellen wie
dieses Land wieder zusammenfindet aber
sie kämpfen damit es gelingt
versuchen die Erwachsenen zu sein weil
die Erwachsenen sich wie Kinder
aufführen
sie wollen uns wie einen Wasserhahn
abdrehen aber unsere Stimmen werden
lauter
Aktivisten Verben bei Minderheiten um
neu Wähler denn diese Wahl entscheidet
über die Zukunft Amerikas
[Musik]
ist ein mutiger Mann nicht weil er sich
an der Nationalhymne versucht nein der
republikanische Senator stellte sich
offen gegen Trumps war Lügen und machte
sich damit Feinde in seiner eigenen
Partei
wir sind auf dem Jahrmarkt den escanabe
im Nordwesten Michigans Amerika hat die
Pandemie hinter sich gelassen vorerst
wirtschaftlich geht es den Menschen
besser in diesem Jahr trotz Inflation
und hoher Benzinpreise finden Sie Jobs
und die sind oft höher bezahlt als
früher der Arbeitsmarkt Bord
die Farmer verdienen erstmals seit
langem wieder Geld mit Fleisch Milch und
anderen Produkten und doch sehen wir
trotz all dem hier nur die Ruhe vor
einem Sturm der Amerikas Demokratie
hinwegfegen könnte so sieht es auch at
MacBook
ich will nicht in einem gewalttätigen
gefährlichen Land leben ich will Frieden
dass die Leute miteinander auskommen
aber wenn du die Menschen spaltest die
Bedeutung von Worten verändert nicht
mehr miteinander reden kannst ohne dass
einer sagt deine Worte sind falsch und
beleidigend wie soll man dann noch
miteinander reden
Mac Boom beschreibt sich als
tiefgläubiger Christ aber fordert beim
umstrittenen wahlthema Abtreibung anders
als viele Parteifreunde einen Kompromiss
doch der Dialog scheint unmöglich
wir leben in dieser Welt in der meine
Leute sagen nein wir müssen uns nicht um
diese Frauen kümmern und die andere
Seite sagt dann ihr seid schlechte
Menschen weil ihr uns nicht zuhören
wollt dabei wollen einige von uns doch
zuhören aber sie schreiben uns alle als
verrückte ab beide Seiten schreiben sich
ab ohne zu versuchen die anderen zu
verstehen
@ und seine Tochter Helen bereiten das
Melken vor die mac-room-familie hat eine
Farm mit 300 Kühen einige davon
präsentieren sie auf dem Jahrmarkt für
den Senator im Wahlkampf auch eine
Gelegenheit sich zu engagieren
muss für alle Farmer die genaue Menge
der Milch notieren denn die produktivste
Kuh wird Ende der Woche prämiert
und die Milch natürlich bezahlt
die Menschen vertrauen ihm und doch
bekommt der Todesdrohungen für das was
der milchpharma nach der
Präsidentschaftswahl 2020 in seinem
zweiten Beruf tat
macroom ist republikanischer Senator im
Parlament von Michigan er wollte den
Vorwürfen von Wahlbetrug auf den Grund
gehen monatelang sichtete sein
Untersuchungsausschuss Dokumente hörte
Zeugen bei kritischen Nachfragen blieben
sie alle Beweise schuldig ein teils
absurdes Theater
schon in der Wahl nach dem November 2020
hatten Trump Anhänger wildeste
Verschwörungstheorien verbreitet die
freiwilligen Helfer beim Auszählen
eingeschüchtert
macroom und seine Kollegen gingen allen
Hinweisen nach auch diesem Video das
angeblich die heimliche Anlieferung von
Stimmzetteln für Joe Biden zeigen soll
in Wahrheit brachte hier der Kameramann
eines Fernsehsenders seine Ausrüstung
für die Berichterstattung ins Gebäude
der Abschlussbericht des Ausschusses ist
eindeutig
es gab keinen organisierten Wahlbetrug
keine Stimmzettel von tausenden von
Verstorbenen die auszählmaschinen und
Ergebnisse wurden nicht manipuliert wer
das verbreite handle unverantwortlich
und schade der Demokratie heißt es im
Dokument
ich habe auch diesmal wieder gelernt
dass meine Vorsicht berechtigt war
nur weil sich etwas so anhört als sei es
war und würde meinen Verdacht bestätigen
darf ich es nicht hinnehmen ohne tiefer
zu bohren
zu viele lassen sich offenbar an der
Nase herumführen von Lügnern und
Betrügern die so hieß es im
Untersuchungsbericht nur auf
persönlichen Vorteil aus sind das ist
brandgefährlich
alles wirkt so ruhig hier am Capitol von
Michigan wir sind in lancing der
Hauptstadt des Bundesstaates 2020 im
Jahr von kobit und politischen Tumulten
standen hier jene die ihre Freiheit
bedroht sein
[Musik]
sie protestierten gegen den Lockdown in
der Pandemie auch mit Waffen in der Hand
sie schüchterten Abgeordnete ein drohten
der demokratischen Gouverneurin ein
Hauch von Bürgerkrieg lag in der Luft
Sturmgewehre als Mittel der
Auseinandersetzung
[Applaus]
in Sichtweite des Parlaments treffen
sich an diesem Abend die Wahlkampf Teams
der Demokratischen Partei die Stimmung
ist gut Joe Biden hat wichtige Gesetze
durch den Kongress gebracht und das
Amerikas oberstes Gericht das liberale
Abtreibungsrecht kippte könnte die Wahl
zu ihren Gunsten entscheiden viele
Frauen sagen Julie und Marie sind
stinksauer
auch die moderaten republikanischen
Frauen und die Babyboomer
dieser Teil der republikanischen Partei
ist wütend dass sie wieder für ihre
Rechte kämpfen müssen
diesmal auch für ihre Enkelkinder
aber die Demokraten haben Angst dass die
Republikaner trotzdem die Mehrheit im
Kongress in Washington erobern viele
Orts liegen Kandidaten vorn die dem
Trump Kult anhängen
sie sind nur eine Mann verpflichtet
Donald Trump
sie beten ihn an als wäre er ein König
aber Amerika wurde auf das Prinzip der
Demokratie gegründet wir haben nicht
immer alles richtig gemacht aber wir
können das nicht zurückdrehen
sie wollen einen Gottesstaat und sie
wollen nur das Beste für Donald Trump
in der Nähe von Detroit stehen sie
Schlange um ihr Idol zu sehen
Trumps Gefolgschaft ist treu nicht
weniger Reisen von Kundgebung zu
Kundgebung
von ihren Anhängern werden die
trumpisten als mega-republikaner
bezeichnet mega wie Trumps Wahl Slogan
make America great again
Germany
Präsident so glauben sie ist übrigens
immer noch Donald Trump
er hat ja nie die Niederlage erklärt er
ist also noch unser Präsident das wissen
nur viele nicht
wir würden gerne auch jene Fragen die am
8 November mit Donald Trumps
Unterstützung gewählt werden wollen aber
die
innenministerkandidatin christina caramo
hat es eilig die Bewerberin für das
Gouverneursamt Tudor Dixon auch
60 Prozent der mega-anhänger sind weiße
Männer christlichen Glaubens 30 Prozent
haben einen Hochschulabschluss ein
Drittel ein mittleres Einkommen
besonders begeistert seine Anhänger wenn
er zum Schluss der fast zweistündigen
Rede unterlegt mit düsterer Musik den
Untergang Amerikas beschwört
[Musik]
Iden
unser geistig beschränkter Präsident ist
nicht fähig das Land zu lenken
das könnte bald zum dritten Weltkrieg
führen
diese Nation hat keine Fähre und freie
Presse mehr ihr kriegt nur Fake News und
die sind die Feinde des Volkes
je düsterer das Bild desto heller
strahlt er für Sie als Geschenk Gottes
um die Nation von allem Übel zu befreien
Jump ist Trump für die Dinge in einer
Art in Ordnung bringen die ihr jetzt
noch nicht versteht
aber seht euch das am Jahresende noch
mal an dann werdet ihr verstehen
die Vereinigten Staaten sind politisch
zutiefst gespalten 25 der 50
Bundesstaaten werden traditionell von
der Demokratischen Partei regiert die
andere Hälfte vor allem im Landesinneren
er von den Republikanern
die ideologischen Unterschiede werden
immer größer als gäbe es in Wahrheit
zwei Amerikas die sich wirtschaftlich
gesellschaftlich und politisch immer
weiter voneinander entfernen rotland und
blauland
blauland ist wirtschaftlich stärker
trägt mehr zum Bruttosozialprodukt bei
die Durchschnittseinkommen sind höher
die Lebenserwartung auch es gibt weniger
Armut aber dennoch mehr Obdachlosigkeit
in rot-land sind die Steuern und die
Häuserpreise im Schnitt deutlich
niedriger es entstehen mehr neue Jobs
aber die Bildungsausgaben sind geringer
die gesundheitsabsicherung ist
schlechter es gibt deutlich höhere
Todesraten durch Waffengewalt und Corona
aber Amerika verändert sich vor allem
durch Zuwanderung tatsächlich können die
politischen Mehrheiten in neuen
Bundesstaaten wechseln mal rot mal blau
die knappen Ergebnisse dort entscheiden
darüber wer die Macht hat in den USA
rotland oder blauland
wir sind an einer Stelle an der blau und
rotland innerhalb von Michigan
zusammenstoßen eine Party der
Republikaner in einem Vorort von Detroit
das zu einem eher demokratisch geprägten
Wahlbezirke hört
weil sie den Medien Misstrauen wollen
diese beiden uns ihre Namen nicht nennen
noch viel mehr Misstrauen sie ihren
politischen Gegnern
die Demokraten wollen die Richtung
unseres Landes ändern sie versuchen
unsere Verfassung abzuschaffen und durch
eine zu ersetzen die sie entwerfen
viele hier glauben an die wahllüge die
Donald Trump weiter verbreitet wir
fragen nach dem Untersuchungsbericht von
Senator at macroom trauen sie ihrem
eigenen Parteifreund nicht
es gibt ja Videobeweise für den Betrug
ein Bild sagt mehr als 1000 Worte
das sind eben wie ich das nenne Sumpf
Republikaner
denen der eigene Job wichtiger ist als
das Wohl des Landes
Christina caramo will Innenministerin
werden und damit höchste staatliche
Aufseherin über die Wahlen in ihrem
Bundesstaat die 37-Jährige ist eine
Newcomerin 2020 will sie in einem
Wahlbüro gesehen haben wie betrogen
wurde der Untersuchungsausschuss fand
heraus dass sie einen normalen
Wahlvorgang falsch interpretiert hatte
trotzdem macht caramo jetzt Karriere wir
fragen Sie nach einer seltsamen Theorie
der sie anhängt die USA sein keine
Demokratie
wir sind eine konstitutionelle Republik
eine Demokratie ist die Herrschaft des
Mops die Republik beschützt die Rechte
der Minderheiten demokratie ist wenn die
Mehrheit die anderen zu todeknüppeln
will das ist Demokratie wollen wir so
eine Gesellschaft oder eine in der die
Rechte der Minderheiten geschützt werden
auch sie will gewählt werden als
Gouverneurin Tudor dexon fordert die
Wähler auf die demokratische
Amtsinhaberin Gretchen Widmer zu feiern
[Musik]
natürlich hat auch Gott seine Rolle in
ihrem Wahlkampf
als wir diese Aufnahmen machen liegen
die republikanischen Kandidatinnen
deutlich hinter den demokratischen
amtsinhaberinnen aber im Oktober konnten
sie noch deutlich aufholen
wir würden mit dicken gerne in Ruhe
reden sie will nicht meine Frage was sie
davon hält wenn Donald Trump Demokraten
als Volksfeinde bezeichnet beantwortet
sie zwischen Müllcontainern
ich habe in meiner Karriere immer auch
mit der anderen Seite zusammengearbeitet
das können wir auch zum Wohle Michigans
tun
aber Dixon und caramo haben mehrfach
signalisiert dass sie die Wahlergebnisse
von 2020 nicht beglaubigt hätten und
dass sie falls gewählt ihren Einfluss
bei der nächsten Präsidentschaftswahl
nutzen könnten
wir besuchen den Sitz der
Bezirksregierung von engham County wie
in jedem Landkreis gibt es hier ein Amt
das für die Rechtstreue Durchführung von
Wahlen sorgt
Barbar Bayram und ihre Kolleginnen in
anderen Kreisen wurden nach der Wahl
2020 von Trump Anhängern eingeschüchtert
der USA Massage einer Kollegin drohten
sie ihren Hund zu töten in ihr Haus
einzubrechen
Wahlbeamte sind zu Feinden geworden so
werden wir genannt aber das sind wir
nicht wir erfüllen nur unsere
gesetzesmäßige Pflicht
Bayram führt uns in den Raum in dem
alles gelagert ist was für die Wahl am 8
November gebraucht wird
in den nächsten Tagen werden die
Materialkisten für die einzelnen
Wahlbüros gefüllt und da steht sogar
eine auszählmaschine der Firma Dominion
von der Trump und seine Anhänger
fälschlicherweise behaupten dass damit
Wahlergebnisse manipuliert werden
könnten
die auszähllisten früherer Wahlen sind
hier aufgehoben alle Stimmzettel an
einem anderen sicheren Ort jederzeit
nachprüfbar
hier lagern die Handbücher für alle
Wahlhelfer Formulare für wahlprotokolle
die alle Beteiligten unterschreiben
müssen
die kommen dann in Umschläge die unter
Polizeischutz zusammen mit den
Stimmzetteln in die Kreisverwaltungen
gebracht werden
die papiersiegel kommen auf alle
Umschläge
ein Demokrat und ein Republikaner müssen
auf den Siegeln unterschreiben Arbeiten
Demokraten und Republikaner auf allen
Ebenen zusammen
in Michigan helfen Demokraten und
Republikaner Wählern und zählen die
Stimmen aus ihre Augen und Ohren
verfolgen die Wahl von der
Programmierung der Maschinen bis zur
letzten Zertifizierung
ja trotzdem werde der Wahlprozess weiter
unterwandert so Bayram einige Wahlleiter
ausnahmslos Republikaner selten Zweifel
an den Wahl sie selbst nennt sich
Verteidigerin der Demokratie sie ist
Mitglied der Demokratischen Partei
da brauchst ein Zug heran und unsere
gewählten Anführer müssen endlich ihren
Anhängern sagen dass die Ergebnisse
richtig waren und dass man mit Würde
verlieren und mit würde gewinnen sollte
wenn Kandidaten die Wahl verlieren
müssen sie ihre Niederlage eingestehen
oder eine Neuauszählung beantragen
wenn sie verloren haben haben sie
verloren und dürfen nicht unsere
Nationen und unsere Demokratie angreifen
Donald Trump hat noch viel Macht über
die Menschen seine glühensten Anhänger
hoffen auf eine Rückkehr zu einer
angeblich heilen Welt aber ihr amerika
steht wie im letzten Jahrhundert für ein
rückwärtsgewandtes Familien- und
Frauenbild Diskriminierung Hetze gegen
Andersdenkende manchmal gar Rassismus
und Hass
Einstellungen die eine Klasse
skrupelloser Politiker befeuert weil sie
damit Macht gewinnen und sichern will
selbst moderate Republikaner geraten
dabei unter Druck in greenspray North
Carolina sind wir mit Christian Castelli
verabredet
er bewirbt sich im sechsten Wahl des
trictum dass Mandat für das
Repräsentantenhaus in
washingtoni besucht seine
Wahlkampfhelfer die per Telefon bei
potenziellen Wählern für ihn werben das
Team ist motiviert mit seinem Wahlsieg
könnten sie dazu beitragen die Mehrheit
im Kongress für die republikanische
Partei zurückzuerobern der ehemalige
Afghanistan Veteran kommt an bei der
konservativen Basis der es vor allem um
die Wirtschaft Inflation Bildung und
Zuwanderung geht
Castelli meidet das Thema Abtreibung
weil es selbst unter Republikanern
umstritten ist er klingt siegesgediss
wir werden Repräsentantenhaus und Senat
gewinnen der große Neustart nach kovid
kommt wenn wir beide kann man erobern
und dann die Rahmenbedingungen schaffen
für den nächsten republikanischen
Präsidenten in zwei Jahren
aber das wird nicht einfach castellis
Wahlbezirk umfasst etwa gleich viele
republikanische und demokratische Wähler
ähnliches gilt in den anderen
Wahlkreisen North caroliners die Grenzen
hatte eine unabhängige Kommission
empfohlen jede Partei bekäme nach
Umfragen wohl je 7 der insgesamt 14
Mandat vorher hatte die republikanische
Mehrheit im Parlament diese Grenzen
beschlossen 10 der 14 Mandate wären wohl
an die Republikaner gegangen aber der
Oberste Gerichtshof des Bundesstaates
stoppte den Plan
unglücklicherweise haben wir hier ein
System in dem die Partei mit den
geringeren Aussichten klagen kann immer
und immer wieder dann hat unser oberstes
Gericht das so entschieden
eine frühere von Republikaner diktierte
wahlkreisgrenze Durchschnitt sogar die
historisch-schwarze lnt State University
mit rund 11.000 Studenten
die wahlrechtsaktivisten wäschtein
hinten und Tyler Svenson erklären uns
wie die Republikaner damals die
Wahlkreise zu ihren Gunsten verändert
hatten
dieser Teil da vorne lag im sechsten
kongressdistrikt
das wenn man in die Mitte ging sich hier
auf diese Linie stellte und die Arme
ausstreckte hatte man sie in
unterschiedlichen Wahlbezirken
weil sich die Stimmen der Studenten
aufteilten blieben die schwarzen den
beiden Wahlkreisen in der Minderheit
die Welt schaut auf unser
demokratie-experiment in Amerika und
sieht wie es manipuliert und verdreht
wird um eine politische Agenda
voranzutreiben deshalb müssen wir
aufstehen und dagegenhalten
die Studenten haben Angst dass ihre
Stimmen bald wieder nicht mehr ins
Gewicht fallen denn die republikanische
Mehrheit im Parlament von North Carolina
hat dem Streit um die Wahlkreise den
Obersten Gerichtshof in Washington
eingeschaltet
niemand könnte künftig mehr klagen auch
sie nicht wenn die konservative Mehrheit
der Bundesrichter urteilt dass die
Mehrheitsentscheidung eines Landes
Parlaments grundsätzlich keiner
richterlichen Überprüfung unterliegt
ein Horror Szenario meint Tyler day er
vertritt die Initiative Carmen course
die befürchtet dass die Republikaner
national garantierte Wahlregeln für
schwarze und Latinos einschränken wollen
um die Macht dem roten Teil Amerikas zu
behalten
es geht nicht nur um North Carolina
sondern ums ganze Land
keine Kontrolle mehr für die
bundesstaatsparlamente
wir könnten einen Rückfall in die 60er
Jahre erleben
als alle Bundesstaaten ihre eigenen
Wahlgesetze hatten
die uralt Regeln und wahlgebühren um
schwarze und Menschen anderer Hautfarbe
vom Wellen abzuhalten
heute ist Wähler registrierungstag ihre
Anliegen werden eher von der
Demokratischen Partei vertreten aber
deren Anführer auch Präsident beiden
halten viele hier für zu alt und schwach
um den trumpismus zu stoppen der das
Land in die Vergangenheit stürzen könnte
es ist ziemlich schwierig wir die junge
Generation versuchen die Erwachsenen zu
sein weil sich die Erwachsenen wie
Kinder aufführen
sie kämpfen für all diese Lügen im
Kapitol und in den Parlamenten der
Bundesstaaten aber wir erwarten von
Ihnen Veränderungen
sie sind eine neue politische Generation
selbstbewusst entschlossen das Land mit
zu gestalten für die meisten steht die
republikanische Partei die einst das
Ende der Sklaverei in einem blutigen
Bürgerkrieg erkämpfte jetzt für
Diskriminierung die Rechtfertigung von
Polizei Brutalität und Rassismus in
einem rotland aller Donald Trump wollen
sie nicht leben ihr Amerika ist ein
anderes als das Amerika von Christian
Castelli
er zeigt uns sein Haus weil das Gericht
den republikanischen wahlkreisplan
zunichte machte müsste er bei einem
Wahlsieg umziehen damit er dann auch im
sechsten Distrikt wohnt kristalli fühlt
sich als Opfer und ist gerade besonders
wütend auf Joe Biden
und Präsident beiden Präsident beiden
hat in einer Rede alle Republikaner mega
Faschisten genannt
das trifft mich persönlich ich bin ein
Patriot ein Veteran mit sechs
Kampfeinsätzen in mehreren Ländern und
es verletzt mich sehr dass ich als
Faschist bezeichnet werde in ita
tatsächlich hatte der Präsident bei
einer Veranstaltung ohne Kameras mega
Republikaner und nur diese als
halbfaschisten bezeichnet
an diesem Abend in Philadelphia dem Ort
an dem einst Unabhängigkeitserklärung
und Verfassung unterzeichnet wurden
vermietet er das Wort
aber Joe Biden warnte eindringlich vor
den trampisten innerhalb der
republikanischen Partei
[Musik]
zu vieles in unserem Land heute ist
nicht normal
Donald Trump und die mega-republikaner
stehen für einen Extremismus der die
Grundfeste unserer Republik bedroht
nicht jeder Republikaner so beiden nicht
einmal die Mehrheit der Republikaner
sein mega-anhänger doch viele ließen
sich einschüchtern
die Demokratie kann nicht überleben wenn
eine Seite glaubt dass es bei einer Wahl
nur zwei Ergebnisse geben darf entweder
sie hat gewonnen oder wurde betrogen die
mega Republikaner verstehen nicht was
jeder amerikanische Patriot weiß du
darfst dein Land nicht nur dann lieben
wenn du gewinnst
manche halten die Inszenierung für zu
alarmistisch aber nach einer Studie
sehen 8% der Amerikaner rund 21
Millionen Erwachsene Joe Biden wegen
Trumps war Lüge als
illegitimen Präsidenten
und halten die Anwendung von Gewalt für
gerechtfertigt um Trump wieder in das
Präsidentenamt einzusetzen
Arizona ist wunderschön aber
gleichzeitig so wild wie die Methoden in
der politischen Auseinandersetzung hier
die Waffe immer am Gürtel für alles
bereit wir sind bei den aufkippers einer
Bürgerwehr nach eigenen Angaben mit
knapp 40.000 bewaffneten Mitgliedern vor
allem ehemalige und aktive Soldaten und
Polizisten sie haben geschworen die
Verfassung zu verteidigen notfalls mit
Gewalt und nicht zu vergessen auch mit
Gottes Hilfe im Gemeindezentrum der
First southern Baptist Church von Gino
Valley
egal wie linksradikal sie sind sie sind
willkommen mit diesem Worten begrüßen
uns Jim Arroyo Chef der aufkeepers im
Landkreis die Teilnehmer lassen sich
heute auf Ernst Fälle vorbereiten
Naturkatastrophen atomkriege den Kampf
um ihr Amerika sind wir eine Miliz ruft
Jim
das FBI bezeichnet die auf Keepers als
paramilitärische Organisation mit
rechtsextremistischem Gedankengut
Anführer des Bundesverbandes waren beim
Sturm aufs Kapitol dabei von dem sich
Jim und sein Verband aber distanzieren
sind wir eine Demokratie ruft er
was dann
eine konstitutionelle Republik weil das
Wort Demokratie in der Verfassung nicht
auftauche sagt Jim wir wollen von ihm
wissen wie wahrscheinlich denn ernst
Fälle wie ein Bürgerkrieg sind
agile
man wirft mir ständig vor dass ich die
Stimmung anheizen und für einen
Bürgerkrieg gegen die Regierung werbe im
Gegenteil wir haben keine Absicht gegen
unsere Regierung in den Krieg zu ziehen
wir wollen nur überleben was immer
politisch geschieht wir haben politisch
aktive Mitglieder aber wir sind in
keiner Weise gewalttätig
Bürgerkriege starten nur wenn
Regierungen außer Kontrolle geraten
und wenn das passiert sollen die
Menschen wissen wie man schwere
Blutungen stoppt bei verletzten das
jedenfalls will er den Teilnehmern heute
beibringen es soll ein Netz von
Gleichgesinnten entstehen die sich
selbst und gegenseitig jederzeit helfen
können natürlich auch bei
Naturkatastrophen aber wir sind mitten
in rotland sie wollen vorbereitet sein
um sich gegen die anderen die Linken
Kommunisten also die aus blauland zu
verteidigen
Kurs Nummer zwei der Umgang mit
Funkgerät schließlich könnte die
Regierung ja die Handynetze lahmlegen
was Sie für den Notfall erlernen könnte
aber auch schon bei der Wahl nützlich
sein sie dürfen mitkommen wenn die
aufkepers die Postkästen für
briefwahlzettel und die Wahllokale
überwachen
und seine Kameraden werden ihre Waffen
mitbringen um Wähler einzuschüchtern
wir werden nicht neben dem
wahlbriefkasten stehen sondern mit
Abstand beobachten unsere Leute sind
nicht autorisiert irgendjemanden
anzugehen wenn du aber mit einer Kiste
von Stimmzetteln kommst oder einem
Rucksack haben wir ein Problem und wenn
du Stunden später nochmal kommst haben
wir ein echtes Problem
diesem wahlbriefkasten kamen sie vor
einigen Tagen doch so nah das Wähler
sich eingeschüchtert fühlten in jener
nach den Mary copaccounty verschwanden
sie rechtzeitig als besorgte Bürger den
Sheriff riefen die deputes vermaßen dann
die Abstände zwischen anderen
Beobachtern und dem Kasten 25 Meter sind
vorgeschrieben
beim Workshop werben die Löwen für die
Freiheit der politische Arm der
aufkeepers um wahlbeobachtet wer lose
kauft kann ein Sturmgewehr gewinnen die
Lions wollen gemeinsam mit anderen
konservativen gruppenkandidaten
aufstellen die das Land beschützen aber
gegen wen
die Leute die uns verraten das Land
zerstören wollen
die Verfassung abschaffen
die wollen uns in ein kommunistisches
Land verwandeln
und wer sind die Leute die Leute die so
etwas tun wollen
die globalisierer der Tiefe Staat die
Liberalen die Fake News
die echten News verbreitet hier die
Patriots free press sie warnt vor
Kommunismus der kovid-lüge der NATO und
Grünen Extremisten beim Lesen fällt uns
der Hass auf wenn es um parteiinterne
trumpgegner geht die angeblich nur so
tun als seien sie auch Republikaner für
dieser republicen sind name only oder
kurz Rhinos erweckt die Chefredakteurin
im Leitartikel die Todesstrafe für
Hochverrat
rechtfertigt Sie also Hinrichtungen
das war drei Jahre hätte ich noch Nein
gesagt weil töten nicht okay ist
andererseits bin ich jetzt überzeugt
dass man wohl ein Exempel statuieren
muss kennen wir uns
und wir müssen vielleicht auch Leute wie
die Clintons enthaupten
[Musik]
und das im Gemeindezentrum einer Kirche
am Stadtrand von Phoenix der Hauptstadt
Arizona sind wir mit Menschen aus der
wichtigsten Wählergruppe des
Bundesstaates verabredet ein Drittel der
Einwohner sind Latinos die er zur
demokratischen Partei tendieren ihr
Durchschnittsalter liegt mit 27 Jahren
zehn Jahre unter dem Schnitt der
Gesamtbevölkerung
künftiger Wähler steht auf dem T-Shirt
es geht auch hier um die Mobilisierung
für die Wahl mit den chicanos polakausa
kämpft Lydia Guzman seit Jahrzehnten für
die Gleichberechtigung der Latinos die
Organisation hilft Menschen in ihrem
Alltag vermittelt Jobs bietet
Fortbildungen an stolz zeigt uns Lydia
ihr junges Team sie wollen nicht Wähler
überzeugen diesmal mitzustimmen die
Latinos sollen laut werden Einfluss
gewinnen
die Menschen hier hatten bisher keine
Stimme sie erheben sie jetzt bei Themen
wie soziale Gerechtigkeit
Immobilienpreise Bildung und Gesundheit
wir wollen dabei mitreden wer uns in
diesen Fragen vertritt
manche Leute wollen uns unterdrücken
abdrehen wir einen Wasserhahn aber wir
sind hier und unsere Stimmen werden
lauter
aber die schikanus polakausa mussten
gerade einen Angriff auf das Wahlrecht
abwehren mit einer Klage stoppten sie
ein Gesetz dass die Republikaner noch
vor der Wahl in Kraft setzen wollten ein
wagerverdacht dass ein Wähler kein
US-Bürger ist hätte ausgereicht um ihn
an der Stimmabgabe zu hindern selbst
nachweispapiere würden nicht helfen weil
schon die Anschuldigungen eine längere
Prüfung zur Folge hätte
das sind Absicht mutwillige illegale
unmoralische taten um Veränderungen zu
verhindern
es geht ihnen darum ihre Macht zu
behalten basierend auf Rassismus
sie haben Angst dass Amerika braun wird
das braune die Macht in den Vereinigten
Staaten übernehmen
die Latinos nennen sich selbst stolz
braune Lydia und Marisa werben für die
Wahl
sie wollen den Menschen sagen dass sie
ihren Einfluss nutzen sollten die
Latinos könnten als die am schnellsten
wachsende Bevölkerungsgruppe in den USA
künftige Wahlen entscheiden
er ist schon für die Wahl registriert
aber viele haben Angst hinzugehen weil
sie von dem Gesetz gehört haben die
schikanos polakausa klären auf dass es
jetzt noch nicht gilt und dass man es
noch stoppen kann wenn die Mehrheiten
bei dieser Wahl wechseln
alleine den letzten Monaten haben sich
weit über 30.000 bisherige Nichtwähler
registrieren lassen auch dank Lydia und
ihrem Team von jungen Helfern
sie machen jetzt die Arbeit die ich vor
25 30 Jahren gemacht habe das begeistert
mich weil sie diese Senatoren
Abgeordneten und Stadträte der Zukunft
sind so wird es sein
wir haben hier eine Menge Hoffnung
erlebt bevor wir weiterfahren aus dem
latinoviertel nach scotsdale einem
Vorort von Phoenix für diesen Abend hat
sich die republikanische
gouverneurskandidatin Carrie Lake
angesagt die Menschen hier gehören eher
zu den wohlhabenderen vor allem weiße
die insgesamt rund 58 Prozent der
Bevölkerung von Arizona ausmachen
sie freuen sich auf die Frau die als
eine Art weiblicher Trump gibt sie
inszeniert sich in ihren Werbespots als
Verteidigerin der Grenze und spricht
gern von Invasion
die 53-Jährige Mutter von zwei Kindern
war bis 2021 eine Kollegin
Nachrichtenmoderatorin Journalistin also
der Wahrheit verpflichtet sie ging weil
die Medien ihr verlogen erschienen dafür
wird sie hier gefeiert und für ihre sehr
persönlichen Attacken auf politische
Gegner
ich will nicht dass Joe Biden sich um
irgendetwas kümmert ich fühle mit ihm
ich hatte eine Großmutter mit Demenz er
ist auch so ein Fall
in den Umfragen liegt Lake zu diesem
Zeitpunkt knapp vor ihrer demokratischen
Gegnerin Katie hopes die eine gemeinsame
Fernsehdebatte ablehnt
Lakes Kritiker nennen sie gefährlich
weil sie zynisch opportunistisch und
damit sehr erfolgreich sein sie ist für
ein totales Abtreibungsverbot verbreitet
Trumps wahllüge und bestreitet ebenfalls
das Amerika eine Demokratie ist
die Theorie scheint uns eine Art Masche
um das Konzept der Demokratie zu
diskreditieren was meinen Sie damit
Amerika ist eine konstitutionelle
Republik und die werden wir behalten ich
bin begeistert dass ich so viele
Patrioten die die Verfassung verstehen
um Ämter bewerben wir werden unsere
Verfassung wieder ehren und
Jedermannsrecht wiederherstellen
ich will sichergehen dass ich sie
verstehe wenn Sie den Verlust von
Freiheiten beklagt ist daran aus ihrer
Sicht also die Demokratie schuld
wenn die liberale Presse fragt ob die
Demokratie in Gefahr ist dann meint sie
damit dass wir keine ehrlichen Wahlen
wollen aber wir wollen ehrlicher Wahlen
in Arizona auf dem Spiel steht dass wir
unser Land verlieren wenn wir eine
weiter offene Grenze haben und keine
ehrlichen Wahlen war die
Präsidentschaftswahl nicht ehrlich ohne
ehrliche Wahlen steht die Demokratie in
unserem Land auf dem Spiel aber ich
erwarte dass sie das verstehen sie sind
ja nicht aus Amerika recherchieren Sie
das mal ein bisschen okay sonst jemand
wie gesagt im schönen wilden Arizona
sind die Methoden eben manchmal etwas
ruhiger
[Musik]
wir sind zurück in blauland in diesem
Fall in Michigans Hauptstadt lancing
beim Nominierungsparteitag der
Demokratischen Partei
Justizministerin Nessel feiert
ausgelassen
[Musik]
die 53-Jährige ist offen lesbisch
verheiratet Mutter von Zwillingssöhnen
ihre ganze Familie bekommt immer wieder
Drohbriefe und Anrufe
ebenso wie die Gouverneurin von Michigan
Gretchen Widmer und ihr Stellvertreter
Garling Gill Quest Widmer wäre bei einer
entführt und ermordet worden
das war jedenfalls der Plan dieser
Rechtsextremisten die ihr Training für
das Kidnapping der Gouverneurin selbst
gefilmt hatten
[Musik]
das FBI konnte sie rechtzeitig stoppen
und hinter Gitter bringen
wie groß muss die Angst der
rechtsextremistischen weißen Rassisten
vor diesem Führungsteam sein dass die
Vielfalt Amerikas widerspiegelt die
dritte Frau im Bunde ist Justin Benson
die Innenministerin die gegen Christina
caramo antritt Benson glaubt dass caramo
falls sie die Wahl gewinnt die
Demokratie von innen aushöhlen wird
hier geht es nicht um Demokraten gegen
re:publikaner sondern um Wahrheit gegen
Lügen entscheiden wir uns auf Basis von
Fakten was für alle das Beste ist oder
folgen wir Verschwörungstheorien Lügen
Gaunern und Scharlatanen die Macht
gewinnen wollen durch Unwahrheiten
wir fahren noch einmal zu dem Mann der
uns beeindruckt hat weil er für seine
Suche nach Wahrheit von seinen
Parteifreunden bedroht wurde
wir finden Senator ed macroom zwischen
den 300 Milchkühen auf seiner Farm im
Westen Michigans
bei der Arbeit im Stall hilft seine
Tochter Helen ohne die Familie könnte
App nicht jeden Montag sieben Stunden in
die Hauptstadt lancing fahren vier Tage
Senator sein bevor er am Freitag wieder
nach Hause fährt
die Namen der Kühe haben die Kinder
ausgesucht die Tiere helfen auch
gewissermaßen mit suchen den Weg in die
vollautomatisierten Melkmaschine
heute hilft ed einer jungen Kuh bei der
Eingewöhnung sobald Ihre exakten Maße
Position der Beine und des Euters im
Melkroboter abgespeichert sind geht es
auch ohne menschliche Hilfe
so ist es für ADS Frau Sarah seine
Schwägerin Susan und die Kinder okay
dass der Senator beste Chancen auf die
Wiederwahl hat macroom konnte sich gegen
einen parteiinternen Widersacher
durchsetzen obwohl er die Lüge von der
angeblich gestohlenen Wahl 2020 entlangt
wegen seines tiefen Glaubens und seiner
Werte drängt sich noch eine Frage auf
sind super sie haben ja gerade von ihrem
Glauben gesprochen und in der Bibel
steht doch an einer Stelle alle die Gott
verehren tun dies in seinem Geist und in
der Wahrheit
Wahrheit Johannes Kapitel 4
Johannes Kapitel 4
also muss man dann nicht alle Politiker
egal welcher Partei offen nennen die das
nicht tun die nicht für die Wahrheit
einstehen nicht für die Wahrheit
aufstehen und die Lügen auf beiden
Seiten
ich versuche es
ich versuche es ich versuche es wirklich
auf beiden Seiten jeden zu benennen der
nicht wahrhaftig ist aber ich muss auch
akzeptieren dass ich nur eine begrenzte
Plattform habe einen begrenzten
Einflussbereich den Gott mir gegeben hat
ich bin nicht landesweit bekannt und
habe keine Glaubwürdigkeit im ganzen
Land
Glaubwürdigkeit und Wahrhaftigkeit
fehlen in Amerika in diesen Tagen mehr
denn je das haben uns unsere Reisen
durch die zwei Amerikas gezeigt
rotland oder blauland die Amerikaner
haben die Wahl
[Musik]